[Music]
all right so when it comes to Russia we
have been telling you for over a year
the Democrats their allies in the
mainstream media have been flat-out
lying to you the American people about
what is really happening now we've also
been predicting that it would only be a
matter of time before they manufactured
hysteria conspiracy theories on Russia
blew up in their faces and that this
entire thing is going to boomerang back
on the Democrats and of course the media
tonight that continues to happen and let
me tell you why
NBC News is out with a bombshell report
here's their own headline Muller is now
investigating Democratic lobbyist Tony
Podesta name sound familiar now he
happens to be the brother of Hillary
Clinton's former campaign chairman John
Podesta and according to NBC News the
special counsel Robert Muller has
launched a criminal inquiry into Tony
Podesta and is lobbying firm the Podesta
group as NBC is reporting Muller's
investigation began by looking into the
finances of former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort but has since now
expanded to include Tony Podesta over
whether his firm violated what is known
as fa ra fara the foreign agent
Registration Act now under the law
lobbyists in the United States who work
for foreign entities they must register
the Department of Justice and disclose
what they're doing and according to NBC
well the Podesta group lobbied for
Ukrainian nonprofit called the European
Center for a modern Ukraine that has
ties to pro-russia political parties in
that country now this is where it gets
interesting as NBC News reports the
Podesta group updated that registration
and about its work with the Ukrainian
group only in June
only after media reports only after
Congress started asking questions this
hypocrisy from the Democrats beyond
stunning now we have heard for over a
year now Russia's a hostile country
Putin such a bad character now it's the
Democrats what do you hear from the
media the corrupt media crickets nothing
Hillary Clinton members of her campaign
they have been attacking President Trump
and claiming there's a Trump Russia
conspiracy collusion
despite zero evidence for over a year
while John Podesta is brother that's
right
John Podesta is brother the guy that ran
Hill
campaign may have broken the law also
tonight John Solomon is out with another
explosive report about Hillary Clinton
take a look at this headline FBI watch
then acted as Russian spy moved closer
to Hillary Clinton
remember the media's reaction the Paul
Manafort and Don junior now according to
the hill the FBI has evidence that when
Hillary Clinton first became the
Secretary of State this is in 2009
Vladimir Putin and the Russians they
launched the campaign to try and gain
access to Hillary her top aides her
husband Bill Clinton and according to
the hill one attempt included a female
Russian spy pretending to be an American
accountant now that spy used that false
identity to secure a job with a major
Democratic donor in the hopes that she
would be able to collect intelligence on
Hillary Clinton in the State Department
well guess what that Russian agent was
eventually arrested and deported as part
of the FBI's massive 2010 spy ring bust
now according to an email that the hill
obtained the Democratic donor who may
have been compromised actually contacted
the State Department to alert Hillary
Clinton about what was happening now we
did reach out to that donor for comment
we didn't hear back shocky and Hillary
Clinton's spokesperson significantly
tries as always to downplay this story
responding to the hill this weekend
claiming oh it's all part of a partisan
distraction in other words the vast
right-wing conspiracy not surprising but
think about this for a second at the
exact same time
Vladimir Putin and Russia are trying to
infiltrate Clinton's inner circle
Hillary is using a private server that
had top-secret specialized access
program classified national security
information on it the mom-and-pop shop
bathroom the same server that was less
secure than your average gmail account
Clinton knew what was happening because
her office commented on the Russia's
firing bus back in 2010 yet she
continued to use the personal server now
that's beyond reckless and it's a direct
threat to national security but that's
only part of it and if that's not
shocking you know if we have John
Solomon and Sarah Carter's reporting
from last week here are the highlights
from last week Bill Clinton he tried to
get the state
Department to give him permission to
meet with Russian nuclear officials
while the uranium one deal was being
approved by the Obama administration and
his own wife and an American lobbying
firm to millions of dollars from a
Russian state-run nuclear energy
corporation while at the same time
providing pro bono services free
services to the Clinton Global
Initiative the Clinton Foundation back
in 2009 now the FBI was doing their job
they discovered evidence including
documents and emails and financial
records they had eye witness accounts
that the Russian nuclear officials
working on behalf of Vladimir Putin and
Russia and Moscow they were engaging in
bribery kickbacks money laundering
extortion and various other types of
racketeering and by the way other
criminal conduct now just before the
deal gets bill gets five hundred
thousand dollars when speaking in Moscow
that's twice as normal speaking fee he
got it from a bank that had an interest
in the Iranian one deal well bill he
tried to meet while he was in Russia
with nuclear nuclear leaders he has to
ask his own wife State Department for
permission but instead he didn't meet
with them he met directly with Vladimir
Putin and the Russian government that
has ties to the bank that's paying Bill
Clinton and has an interest in uranium
one why because Vladimir Putin he wanted
to control over America's uranium market
and what is so inexcusable is that the
Obama administration Hillary Clinton
Eric Holder so many others they let this
happen and in 2010 the uranium one deal
it was approved it gave Vladimir Putin
what he wanted control of 20% of
America's uranium supply the
foundational material for nuclear
weapons who would ever do this and we
also learn from the hill and circuit
news.com the FBI has evidence including
testimony they have an informant that
Russian nuclear officials funneled
millions of dollars to the Clinton
Foundation while Hillary was serving as
Secretary of State and personally
signing off on the Iranian one deal in
the first place that gave the uranium to
Putin and it turns out the informant was
blocked by the Obama administration from
exposing to Congress what was happening
New York Times also reported back in
2015 that the Russian nuclear company
uranium one was actually even exporting
yellowcake uranium outside of our
country to Canada now even though they
didn't have a license so we have no idea
what Putin is done with it where it's
ended up did it go to North Korea to go
to Iran there's also several key
officials that need to testify about
what they knew and when they knew it
for example the former attorney General
Eric Holder he oversaw the FBI the FBI
had all this information about bribery
kickbacks and money laundering in 2009
that was his job he was also a member
Eric Holder was of the committee that
approved uranium one along with Hillary
so he had to know what was going on then
you've heard the name Rod Rosenstein he
appointed Mueller Special Counsel
looking in a trump Russia collusion he's
the Deputy Attorney General now he
actually helped lead the FBI
investigation into the Russian bribery
scandal and we have the special counsel
himself Robert Muller well back in 2009
he was the FBI director during this
entire scandal and now we're supposed to
trust Muller is going to investigate
Russian interference fairly objectively
and honestly when he didn't tell
Congress about the Russian bribery plot
and crimes that the FBI said they knew
were being committed this is inexcusable
it's also another reason Muller needs to
go and he needs to go immediately
there's also the fact that Robert Muller
has a troubling track record as a
federal prosecutor take a look at this
headline from Fox news.com quote Muller
team criticized by fellow attorneys for
his history of questionable tactics now
a criminal defense attorney is saying
that Muller tried to entrap him while
the now special counsel was working as a
prosecutor in Boston the same attorney
also warned that mullahs Russian probe
well should be met with skepticism and
tonight congressman Ron De Santis says
the House Oversight Committee is now
investigating this uranium 1 deal
congressman De Santis
also revealed some stunning information
about the FBI informant let's take a
look at this I've been able to speak
with the confidential informant that
helped the FBI on
this bribery scheme I've spoken with his
attorney and this informant wants to
tell his story but he's currently under
a nondisclosure agreement that was
signed with the Eric Holder Justice
Department he came forward in 2016 was
threatened with reprisal from the
Loretta Lynch Justice Department we have
the money that went to Bill Clinton for
the speech the half a million dollars
millions of dollars to the foundation
from sources connected with uranium one
and then you had the approval of the
deal on the cepheus board which Hillary
Clinton was a member of in 2010 so you
do have the quid you have the quo this
in this informant I believe would be
able to link those two together because
he was right at the heart of a lot with
a lot of what was going on at the time
you see what's happening since we've
been covering this because John Solomon
Sarah Carter have done amazing
investigative work maybe and we've been
covering on it on this show now Congress
is getting it now think about this maybe
what Ron de Santos would say maybe
that's the reason why the Obama
administration blocked this FBI
informant from talking because he might
be able to expose the criminal conduct
from the Clintons and others within the
Obama administration now whatever
non-disclosure agreement this informant
apparently signed with the Obama
Department of Justice it needs to be
ripped up and it can be ripped up by the
Trump administration by the Justice
Department you the American people
deserve to know the truth about the
Clintons and how they sold out your
national security and finally tonight in
just a pathetic display and despite
mountains of evidence and now two
congressional investigations Hillary
Clinton is saying oh she did nothing
wrong
during the uranium one deal and Clinton
is also attacking President Trump Fox
News and yeah even yours truly because
we're telling you the truth
watch this Sean Hannity on his program
has been very critical of the uranium
one deal the president saying with
regard to Russia that's the real story
in all of this what would you say to
those critics I would say it's the same
baloney they've been peddling for years
and there's been no no credible evidence
by anyone Trump and his allies including
Fox News
are really experts at distraction and
diversion so the closer the
investigation about real Russian ties
between Trump associates and real
Russians as we've heard jeff sessions
finally admit to in his testimony the
other day the more they want to just
throw mud on the wall and I'm their
favorite target me and you know
President Obama we're the ones that they
always like to put into the crosshairs
the vast right-wing conspiracy is back
Hillary I have a few questions for you
why would you ever give Vladimir Putin
the man you've been telling us is so
horrible and Russian of course our
biggest enemy why would you give them
twenty percent of America's uranium the
foundational material for nuclear
weapons why would you ever do that why
did your husband get twice the amount of
money that he usually gets for a speech
in Moscow and at the time of the deal he
meets with Vladimir and by the way I
have another question
Hillary Clinton why did you do why did
you take hundred forty five-plus million
dollars from all the people associated
with this deal and will you go under
oath and answer questions I doubt it you
don't want to do you